Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to: Where Bunnies Fly
I shouldn't need to explan why this game must be played!
Look!
It's a fricken sad looking little bunny in a hot air balloon TrYiNg To Go ThRoUgH ThAt GoD dAmN rAiNbOw!
IT'S FUCKING ADORABLE!
FUUCK!
So i found this game because apparently it has a high score ranking system,
on GameJolt, where I found it
and
you know me!
I am here...
to try and get the best score possible in absolutely every-
-oh I'm going okay hang on
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO PLAY
WOAHH
OH IT'S BEAUTIFUL!
Oh go Bunniplier, go!
Oh harvest eggs..
Easter eggs from the clouds.
Now i don't know entirely how that works but.. I think i spot one up there.
I'm coming for ya!
Eventually.. before i run out of fuel.
Ohhh it's not gonna get there is it?
I just want one!
Yay!?
Did I get it?
AHHHH
What? Fuel empty!?
I GOT IT!
okay
alright, restore 10  fuel per egg delivered.
I don't know what that-how
wooaah
mountain
oh!
First delivery acheived.
YAY!
I don't fully understand but i think i need that carrot for fuel
I don't think I'm gonna make that
I don't know how I'm gonna make that but I don't think I'm gonna- shit
I'm not gonna do that
Find a carrot before you crash
Oh no!
Is there a chance of Bunniplier here dying?!
I didn't know that was part of the contract
I thought I was gonna be totally okay
Ohhhhh
I'm gonna die!
Awww gawd
INCOMING BUNNY
SAVE ME
Oh
Awwwwww
*laughs* Okay
Goddamnit!
Aww,  I thought it was going to be a horrible explosion and,
And then bunny bits are going to be thrown across the valley
I must get the highscore
NO matter what.
*strange noise*
*More strange noises*
Okay
Just gotta conserve it
So that..
Ohhh
I gotta follow the slip stream
Ehh, there slip streams
Ooo
Okay, so
Aw jeez, Im not not gonna get high enough
''Oar I''
OAR I?
AM OAR I?
AHHHH
TITS
I missed it :C
Goddamnit >:C
HOW CANT THIS BE SO HARD
AWWWWW
IM GONNA MISS THE RAINBOW
Awww, look at the little bun-bun c:
Awwww, he's soo cute! :3
Weeee!
Oh I dunno how to play!
*burbs in mouth*
I dunno what im doin'!
Can I get dat? :3
Yeeah I can get dat >:3
yyyeah!
yeehh
-Okay
whoa
's'like a cris-cross nightmare of slip-streams goin' on here
K, so if I can ride this up...
I can probably get to...
Ooooh
More upward speed
-Yes
I can combo a few
Okay-
Up, up, up, up, up, up
AWWW
C'MON!
I SO HAD THAT!
Ooo- get this one
Boink!
Okay-
Ooup- there's one hidden in the clouds-
OOOOO-
I'M OUT
Oooouh I dunno how to do that
-Deliver to the rainbow portals
I'm not gonna be able to get that >:T
I don't have enough carrot power to be able to go any faaarther D:<
I'M-
FUBBERNUCKED!
I'm a goddamn stupid stranded baby bunny >:(
baby bunny :3
Bunny baby :)
okay- So...
'Restore 10% fuel per egg delivered'
which means that I'm probably gonna be able to get a little bit of fuel back
But I dunno about-
*groans*
I dunno about the *mmmmmm*
C'mon, C'mon, C'mon
Wuoosh!
Okay so I got some fuel
I gotta be veeerrrrry conscious of it
Veerry verr-
-Oh jeez
There's a carrot!
I can make it!
Aaaah!
Eouh
I can make it-
I can barely make it
Eeuh
*ready to ejaculate*
*almost there*
AWWWH C'MON!!
I WUZ RIGHT THERE! ;A;
I WAS RIGHT ON TOP OF THE BLEE (?)
BOOM!
SPLAT!
*cartoon-ey sounds of entrails being flung forth*
Bleaugh!
Bunny bitz everywhere...
Okay
Soo
I'm gettin' the hang of it
Everybody bare with me
But I'm get the hang of this and then I'm gonna win this
Yer gonna see
You're gonna see the high score bunny-man
The expert bunny maker (what-)
-That is me (okay)
I'm the best bunny >:3
The best biggset
bounciest
-Bunny
With the biggest bazzoons
(O.o)
k-
WHOOAA-
Gotta carrot
Nooice >:)
Increase fuul capoosity (Fuel capacity)
Cap-
Caploos-
plll *melts*
Maybe it's like a fools errand to go up
Cause I saaw...
I-I can't control the camera, by the way so I-I saaww
Ooo
I saw-
Right dere ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Right dere!
-okay
I go slow...
Nice and navigate it
Land it
Eat it-
Munch it down >:D
Crammit in your face!
Waaaah!
Ouh it wa-
I got it, I got it
-okay
I didn't know if I got it er not
Okay, so I'm gonna follow the slip-stream up...
...And the rainbow...
And them I'm gonna be able to get up into the clouds and be able to get what I need.
Slip-stream it
Slip-stream it!
Twitch-stream it (wha-)
Damn it, it's not enough
There's a slip-stream over there goin' straight up
I'm gonna go for that one
euhn
Go, go
Go baby, go
~oooooouh~
Rising!
Not enough, tho
-need more
aah
C'mon
k- Bonk!
Thats one
There was another over here...
awh- I saw another one!
Oh jeez
Okay I'm-
I'm up above
I'm way high up
okay
Think I can get this one...
Yeh, yeh, yeh, yeh, yeh, yeh-
AWWWWH-
C'MON!
IT'S RIGHT THERE!
Okay, at least I can refu-
Whhyyyy ?-?
ahg damnit
I don- this is not the time for a slip-stream!
I need to go for this carrot
Or else I'm gonna be
dumb
Oh where'd it go?
Oh there it is
Okay-
So I can go down
Alright we got this carrot
'Find a carrot before you crash'
I got it
Iiiii got it!
I can keep this up indefinitely if I...
-stop sucking so badly
I'm the worlds greatest sucking bunny (◡‿◡✿)
-Here we go
Lock on target!
LOCKED ON TARGET!
*HULK SMASH*
AAAAAAAHHHG
Riiiiiise- okay
So thats good
Man, we got a lot-
oh
'Fifty percent fuel capacity' Holy shit that's a lot
Why is it so generous?
Why am I so suspicious of how generous it is
Okay, I'm gonna not go for that one
I'm gonna go for these
...here...
... in this cloud...
...Cluster
yess >:)
Yess! >:D
Bam!
Got it
Okay
That's another one
Can't see any more up case the camera angle's a biiiiiitch~♪
ahh shit!
(mumbles): gah- shitty tits
Okay- wait- there's one right-
oh-
I- Eeeauh
Aaeeh!
Aaahg!
There's one in there!
There's one in the goddamn clouds here!
I saw it >:I
God damn it- I saw-
I saw it!
Aaauhg
I saw it
God damn it
Damn slip-streams
I don't need this much
I don- I don't need this much stream-slippin'
I'm the most-
Luuuubed air balloon in the sky
♪~awwwwwwwhh~♪
Boink!
Ouh tried-
duh- Aiiegh-
d'arrgh
*'D'arrgh' Intensifies*
augh I can't go backwards can I
But I can go down to that one down there and then hop-jump to that one
Ooooh I can do a triple
OOOOOH BABY A TRIPLE
'Heavy load'?!
I don't have a heavy load >:(
Not right now anyway
And we're not gonna talk about the connotations of what that statement meant
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
SHUT UP!
*Mark noise*
Boink!
-okey
That's another one
-okay
So I have to get... this one
Boink!
aaah
Who's the bunny master-
Ooaah I'm gonna get a quadruple!
NAOOOOO D:<
I WAS GONNA GET A QUADRU-
AAUGH THERE WAS ANOTHER ONE HIDDEN IN THE-
GOD DAMN IT
*MMMMMM*
Fubbernuckin'-
Piece a'
SHIT
I can't believe how seriously I'm taking this stupid game about...
Well actually it's not stupid at all
Usually I'm sarcastic and I say the game's stupid just because I'm not- It's not goin' my way
-But this is actually...
It's really pleasant...
I mean I imagine it'd be more pleasant if I wasn't screamin' like an idiot but I can't help it because I wanna WIIIN...
But it's just really pleasant to see like-...
...how nice it is
You're just f-
It's- it literally the only objective is to collect Easter eggs... in the clouds
This is like a fever dream... but it's my kinda fever dream
I like this a lot
Ooo!
And I believe its probably this whole-
whuooaaaaaayyo whoa whoa
Mountain, mountain, mountain
Yeeaas!
Yaaass!
Mountainmountainmountain- Okay
And I believe like- thi- this is my kinda fever dream
*stutters*
I believe it's an infinity generated landscape, too which is awful-
-Like a really cool little feature about this game
And it's beautiful!
It's stylized
I mean it's not like-...
"Super-high-poly-count-amazing-graphics" but-
In it's own way...
It's stylized to be perfect to what *it* is and thats-
That's all I really ask outta games
Is that it is what it should be and this just-
This game is just so pleasant (◕ ꒳ ◕✿)
Anyway, that's all that-
That's all the thoughts I have about the game
...itself
(impersonates self): back to my screaming like an idiot
AAAAAHG C'MON!
I was so clooose...
damn it (´∩｀。)...
oooouh this is gonna be a death defying one
I'm gonna have to curtail (?) the mountains
Pull a han-
Hang a sick U-ie ⊂(▀¯▀⊂)
~ooooh~
Get up- yep- up- up -up
Right-
Yeu- AAAHG
UP!
OOOOUUUUHH
SSSSSSSS-
SNARKIES (wat)
Wouuuuuh
That is not a lot of control I have there
Hooooley shit
Hoooley shit
Awh, c'mon-
Gimme that one
Gimme fuel, Gimme fire, gimme that which I-
(Darth Vader): NOOOOOOOOOOO
Damn it I wasted all that fuel for nothing
I thought I was gonna be able to get that
God damn it of course it's gonna waste my tiiiime
naw- but maybe I can drift down on the top of this mountain and scrape down a few eggs-
WHAT THE HELL AM I SAYING???
God, I'm strategizing about this but it just sounds like I'm totally out of my mind
(Mocks self): Imma just float my bunny in the balloon down this mountain
Grab a few moar gigantic Easter eggs that magically shrink into my basket
And then I'm gonna drift down through another rainbow that's gonna shoot me off into the sky!
It's gonna be great!
Better be careful and get for more carrots so that I don't run outta fuel
Cause everybody knows if you burn carrots
((((；゜Д゜)))
IS THAT A DOUBLE RAINBOW?!
(ల◕ั˘๐◕ั˘ల)
Ouh it's so beautiful! (❁´ω`❁)
*mmmMMMMMM*
Here we go
Oh thread the needle baby
Ouh yeah~
'Fuel refilled' -thank you very much
*constipation*
Gotcha
whouh... almost... got... killed...
oh-
That's a trap!
Oh this is a trap rainbow
-Rainbow trap
Okay so I don't believe this game has an end
I believe this game is just meant to be played to get as high score as you feel like it
And it seems to me like, once you get the hang of it, you can really keep going forever like I don't see...
How I could die unles I get...
...crammed into a verrry precarious situation but-...
It's really cool!
I like this game a lot
And... its the second bunny game that I've played in recent time
I think that-
*surprise ejaculation*
Apparently that didn't even kill me so it's gonna be totally fine so-...
Lemme know what high score you can get outta this game-
It's totally free to play, by the way
Maybe you can log your high scores on Game Jolt itself so-...
Thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always...
I will see you...
In the next video
Buh byyyee!
♪~Soooooome wheeeeeeere oooverr the raaaaainboooooooow...~♪
♪~waaaaay uuuuuup hiiiiigh~♪
♪~There's aaaaaaa buuuunny in a basket~♪
♪~colleting easter eggs up hiiiiiiiiiiiigh~♪
(Not so musically): sooooooomeWHEEER!-
ok bye